uh great to have you on the program this
morning so you are at the coronation
yesterday any particular highlights I
mean the whole thing it was an amazing
event and I thought especially against
the backdrop of things not working in
our country across the board great to
see so many things that make our country
great on display whether it was the
music the spectacle the military
processions the fly pass the
celebrations of people coming right
together across the the country it was
just an amazing moment to be there and
also really nice talking to people in
The Abbey who had been chosen to attend
because of their voluntary service their
community service their Public Service
which I thought actually spoke to
directly to what Justin will be the
Archbishop of Canterbury was saying
about the theme of the coronation so you
know around service to others looking
out for other people so really wonderful
occasion and obviously a massive
privilege to be there a bit of a
royalist then I am I I think our
constitutional monarchy has served us
really well
um and I think that you know 300 million
people I think it was watching right
across the world
um is a good thing for our country
actually and you know just reflecting
back on some of the royal visits we've
had in in my Borough over the years
anyone who met
um the late Queen anyone who's met
senior members of the royal family it's
a really special moment actually and a
way to
um I think recognize and celebrate
people in a way that wouldn't quite be
the same if we'd had a different system
you mentioned the lake Queen there who
obviously people felt such affection for
and you know an honor towards what kind
of King do you think Charles will be I
think he'd be a good King I think we
know that he cares about a range of
causes but of course now he's the king
and puts some of that to one side but I
think do you think he should have had
some of that as on side then well of
course he has to but as a head of state
uh it's it's the responsibility of the
king or the queen to bring people
together and I think there are ways in
which the royal family on issues of
consensus and important and issues of
important National significance or
International significance can bring
people together whether that's on issues
like tackling climate change or actually
the role of the monarchy as part of
Britain's soft power their diplomatic
pulling power there are lots of ways in
which the royal family add enormous
value to our country collectively let
alone those special moments of the
garden parties and the Royal visits and
you a bit about the
the policing of what happened because it
happened
there have been people protesting the
coronation now the Met released a
statement they said we understand public
concern following arrests made this
morning we police proportionately and in
the context of the event it's a Once in
a generation moment that's been a key
consideration
do you think the police response has
been proportionate well firstly I'm glad
that the police are providing context
and recognize the accountability that
comes with policing I think Mark Rowley
the Metropolitan Community Police
Commissioner knows that there's a lot of
work to do to rebuild trust with the met
in particular so that transparency and
that accountability is important I think
it's also important to recognize that in
Trafalgar Square for example there was a
significant Republican protest that took
place peacefully without incident
um you know as you said I'm someone who
supports the monarchy but I respect
people who have a different View and I
respect their right to protest and I
think the police does too there are of
course some cases that being raised
probably not important I don't comment
on specific cases while there are
potentially still investigations or
action ongoing but that accountability
piece is going to be really important
and to make sure that the policing was
proportionate and to make sure that
where people have concerns that they're
addressing I understand you don't want
to talk too much about specifics but I
do want to talk about some of the
specifics I think it is quite important
to give the overall picture you know
because for example three people
reportedly arrested volunteers with the
night Stars program so that's in
Westminster council's Street safety
program handing up rape alarms and this
kind of thing is quite worrying as you
say there is concern about policing by
consent as it is yeah and and it's that
principle that's important policing by
consent I know Westminster city council
has put out a statement expressing
concern and asking for that to be looked
into I think that's an important thing
to do and if the police have been
disproportionate or got things wrong
it's important as we've seen with the
Casey review that they hold their hands
up and acknowledge it I'd also just
acknowledge that days like yesterday are
really difficult for the police it's an
enormous Security operation there were
concerns I know I got it right then
that's what I'm trying to get let me
look the truth is Sophie um you know I
didn't wasn't there didn't see not
across the details of specific cases yet
and so I don't think it's appropriate
for me to provide a running commentary
without all of the facts I think it's
the accountability that's important and
where concerns have been raised whether
that's
um you know by Republic
um you know the the campaign for um an
elected head of state
um or people more generally just
concerned about what they've read in the
papers or seen on the Telly it's
important that the police provide that
accountability in principle then
anti-monarq protesters are they in your
eyes is it reasonable for them to go
along peacefully protest but noisily
protest for example yeah
um if if you're a republican of course
you're going to protest around the
coronation if you're not going to do it
around the coronation when would you and
I don't agree with them but I absolutely
respect their rights protests and
actually in terms of things that make me
proud of our country and our democracy I
think it's the fact that you can have
those two events taking place
simultaneously the spectacle in the
Abbey thousands of people packing the
mail the street Parts across the country
and have that space for people to
express a different view to protest
that's one of our strengths as a country
and I think there's one reflection I
just offer as a politician actually
reflecting on the divisions in our
country many of them political divisions
we've got to learn the art of being able
to disagree well in Britain and to hold
different views I would strongly hold
them robustly debate them but to do so
in a way that's respectful and and you
know I don't agree with the Republican
protesters out yesterday I absolutely
respect them I think their point of view
is legitimate and I respect their right
to voice their views
right let's talk local election shall we
you must be pretty pleased with the
result we are very pleased we're I mean
we the results that we saw right across
England in every corner of England were
encouraging I mean important end of the
of themselves I should say for those
labor local government leaders who are
now going to be able to do things to
deliver for their communities having one
power in places like Plymouth and Medway
as well as in the north of England as
well uh you know games right across the
the country
I think for the next general election
labor feels confident but not complacent
and I want to make sure that both of
those things are heard because yes I
think those results do point to enormous
progress made under kirstalma's
leadership he's changed the labor party
now he's got hearings to be able to
change the country but there's more to
do and our labor has said
know that you're on course for a
majority of the next election and I'll
be honest I
Reland how you've got there okay so what
the experts are saying is yes it's great
but you wouldn't get a majority and if I
will look now I think we can have a look
at the House of Commons projection from
Rollins and Thrasher so these are the
experts I know you're going to say look
you can't read across from local
elections to general elections
but according to this you wouldn't be on
course for a majority would you and this
is because you know you're starting from
such a bad place frankly at the last
election that you need such an enormous
swing to get there and these results
don't put you on course for a majority
well you're you're right Sophie I am
going to say that these are you can't
read across but it is important to say
that this is this is not um a prediction
for the next general election this is
what would have happened if the local
elections have been a general election
and they weren't for a number of reasons
okay let me let me show you another
graph then in that case I want to show
you these the council a graph going back
in time historically and I think we can
bring that one up because I understand
the concerns about the majority
predictions the House of Commons
projection but let's have a look at this
this is Council suits going back through
time and because you're starting from
such a bad place you would need an even
bigger National swing from the
conservatives than in the 1997 landslide
and if you analyze the local elections
you're around nine to ten points ahead
but at this point before the 1997
election Tony Blair was about 14 points
ahead in 1996. so you wouldn't get there
would you it's not showing that you'd on
course for a majority well I'd say two
things one is if you told us in 2019
that this is where labor would be four
years following that worst defeat since
1935 I don't think anyone would have
said that was possible but Kirsten has
changed the labor party and earned us a
hearing with the voters who turned their
backs on labor and people are turning to
labor again that's why I say we're not
complacent we know that there is more
work to do to earn people's trust and
support but on the basis of the results
we saw on Thursday we are confident that
labor can win a majority in terms of our
policies for the next general election
in terms of the results that I think we
will get the next general election The
Best Is Yet To Come would you be
prepared to go into account Mission with
the Liberals we're not even entertaining
that Prospect Sophie because directly
not even I'm not I just don't think that
is the scenario that we're going to be
in after the next general election if it
is which is very possible looking at
these results
I honestly think Kia starmer could
literally be on the way to the Palace in
the car having just been cut summoned to
be prime minister of a majority party
and the conservative party in some parts
of the media's talking points would
still be always a difficult night for
the conservatives but labor could have
done better come on I I'll give you my
word that if that is a scenario that
happens I will not be asking these
questions however in these scenarios
where the results Point towards a hung
Parliament it is a legitimate question
to answer no no I think we're this is a
this is a process not an event we're not
at the Final Destination yet in terms of
the general election and just give you a
couple of examples as to why we
shouldn't read the local elections um
right across take whole where I say
through gritted teeth the liberal
Democrats did rather well I heard the
lib Dem leader of whole Council the
other night saying well look locally
people have voted lib Dem but the
general election people in the city vote
labor in Worcester where again mildly
through gritted teeth the greens did
rather well again I heard the green
saying well local elections we fight
locally but at the general election this
will be a labor versus conservative
fight and I'm confident that we will win
Worcester for for labor but we're not
complacent about this and there's so
much more still to come kirstan was
going to be setting out labor store in
terms of our big missions to not just
cut NHS waiting lists but build an HS
fit for the future later this month if
that'll be followed Again by our bid
education opportunity in terms of
educational opportunities narrowing the
Gap in life chances between kids from
working class backgrounds like mine and
more wealthier backgrounds there's so
much more that labor has in store and so
much ambition for our country and that's
how we'll win the next general election
let's talk about this shall we because
if you are going to be the government
waiting are you going to need some big
radical ideas and last week kistama told
me that the NHS isn't on its knees it's
on its face so what's the big radical
idea for the NHS are you willing to take
on the vested interests so as well as
delivering the biggest expansion of NHS
staff in history funded by abolishing
the non-dom tax status more doctors more
nurses more NHS staffs to bring down how
much has that um raised in London tax
day just over three billion pounds and
the NH because if you look at the
overall budget that's kind of it's not
exactly a huge injection of money is it
well I just say yeah two things on that
firstly we know that investment matters
the last Labor government showed that
but so does reform again the last Labor
government showed that too we managed to
deliver the lowest weighting lists and
the highest patient satisfaction in
history in the NHS by that combination
of investment and reform so to your big
idea challenge we've got to shift the
focus of healthcare out of the hospital
into the community because if we can fix
the front door to the NHS in primary
care where GPS are currently overwhelmed
there are thousands fewer GPS now than
there were before we've got people
waiting far too long to see a GP because
the GPS we have are desperately over
stretched and burned out if we can get
that front door to the NHS fix it means
faster diagnosis which means more
effective treatment and less expensive
because if you go and see a GP it costs
about 40 quid for an appointment if you
go to accident emergency it costs about
360 pounds so GPS are convinced by your
plans though and the BMA have told me
that you know you're not they're not
sure that you'll really understand the
Health Service well we're winning people
around I think it's fair to say in terms
of General perhaps I spent a lot of time
not just during the election campaign
but previously actually our in general
practice talking to GPS and the wide
range of Staff who work there I think
they they aren't they get the most
important thing which we recognize that
they're they're stretched there aren't
enough of them uh we need to get the
Cavalry in to support them but I think
they also see and I did a big speech at
the king's fund just weeks ago that if
we're serious about having an NHS that
fit for the future that means having
Better Community Health Services faster
access to primary care so that we can do
faster diagnosis more effective and less
expense treat which is better for
patients and better for the taxpayers
should private sector involvement in the
NHS be a dirty word
uh no I mean we're going to have to use
the private sector to bring down NHS
waiting lists um the last Labor
government did that very successfully
that was that was part of the picture I
think the anger I feel today is that so
many people are feeling forced to go
private because the NHS is unable to get
to them in time and that's created a
two-tier system where those who can pay
a seem faster and those who can't are
left behind and that's why I've said you
know we would use the private sets to
bring down an HS waiting list because
for me it's not just a pragmatic point
it's a point of principle why should
someone who's working class or you know
short of cash be left behind while
they're next door neighbor is able to be
seen faster but I see that as a as a as
a measure on the path to making the NHS
so good that no one feels forced to go
private because that's what happened
under the last Labor government use of
the private sector fell over the course
of that government because the NHS was
so good people said well why pay the NHS
is there okay well if you are a health
Secretary of the general election we'll
have come back and we'll see if the NHS
is people will still be saying oh but
could care storm have done better oh
yeah well let's have a seat let's see
we'll we'll talk about the election
results as they come in as we will do
with the government
now with more scrutiny there's always
scrutiny about past Pleasures about
um people changing their minds and I
just want to play you one quick clip of
I think you'll probably remember know
where I'm going with this one but let's
have a quick listen
there's no easy way to say this
we made a pledge
we didn't stick to it
and for that I am sorry
when you've made a mistake
now labor has ditched its pledge to
scratch tuition fees are you getting the
cameras in for your own Sorry video
[Laughter]
look I think the the important thing is
learning from the liberal Democrats
experience you don't go into a general
election making promises you can't keep
and we're not prepared to do that and
the truth is the public finances are in
such a mess that there are lots of
things that we would like to do that in
all honesty we don't think we will be
able to afford to do now I think I was
talking to you back in the day when I
was president of the national English
students about some of these issues I
I've never supported the tuition fee
system the way it is it's actually
become worse more unfair on students and
graduates since I was president of nus
about 15 years ago
and we want a fairer funding system and
that's what label be setting out plans
for you say sorry to those people who
voted for care style were in the
leadership election on this pledge that
he then broke well they're labor party
members and I think labor party members
totally understand where we are as a
pastor will you say sorry to people who
voted on a false pledge I don't well no
I think people know that in terms of
what kirstan was stood to be leader of
the labor party on the platform he's
still put on making labor electable
again getting us bats power so we can do
things labor members absolutely support
Kia stammer in that and they will
understand better than anyone else
because they're out there knocking on
doors they're a huge part of achieving
those results we saw on Thursday night
they know that more than anything else
it's important that when people pick up
Labor's Manifesto and they look at our
pledges and they look at how they'll pay
for them because it'll be fully costed
and fully funded they they know that
voters need to know that we can deliver
every single one of those pledges and if
Kier is looking at the state of the
economy and the public finances of
Rachel Reeves and concluding there are
things that he would have liked to do
but can't afford to do far better to
make those big judgment calls now before
a general election than end up
apologizing after a general elections
the British people like Nick Clegg was
forced to do look what happens to the
lib Dems we're not going to make those
mistakes we will set out plans for a
fairer funding system though because I
don't think anyone in the labor party
thinks the status quo we see for
students today where they feel real
hardship in their pockets or graduates
who pay their student loans off but
still see the bill Rising um year after
year we know that's not a fair funding
system we'll set out our fully costed
fully funded plans for what we can do on
higher education and student finance but
the reassuring Point labor will not have
promises in our Manifesto that we can't
pay for and keep okay thank you